Hi everyone. In this section, we're going to go over how to use Web Remote using Level Snapshot Interaction,
and we're going to control one of our lights using our RCP and our Web Remote tools.
So let's get started.
You'll see on my screen here on the left that I have two tabs.
I have one tab that has my light properties all placed in, which I demonstrated how to do earlier.
And we also, underneath on the left here, we have a Snapshot tab.
Now, you're probably wondering, how did I get to this particular spot?
What I did was I simply clicked on plus, and when I clicked on plus, I can choose Snapshot.
And that's basically how I got that rolling and working in the right direction.
So what I'm going to do now is I'm going to go to my iPad,
and you're going to watch me interactively control these scenarios.
And we're going to start first with our Snapshot.
So I'm going to walk over here just to prove to you that we're not using any editing voodoo for this.
We're interactively changing this.
And we're working in 5.1 for this particular feature.
So I'm working with this iPad here, and you'll notice I have several different lighting scenarios loaded within my RCP.
And we have it connected right now directly inside of our web remote.
Now, you'll see, because we chose that Snapshot in the very beginning, which you saw me do on the menu,
it's now loaded all of my Snapshots, so it recognizes them.
You'll also notice that I have a Take Snapshot at the top, so you do have that option too.
These are game changer concepts here, because before you could load your Snapshots and you could work with them,
but because Lumen wasn't quite there yet, it wasn't fully optimized, you'd have to pre-bake a few things,
and then your scene would have to be pretty bare bones if you're working with Lumen.
Lumen is optimized quite well here, and you'll see that we also have water moving in the background.
We have a decent scene.
Now, again, everything within context, everything with a grain of salt,
you can always put things to a complete halt if you put too many stuff in there.
So just always think about optimization when you're working with things.
But you'll notice we have our scenes loaded perfectly in here, which is great,
and I don't have to rebuild any lighting here because I'm using Lumen,
and I'm loading these on the fly, and I can have quite a bit if I needed,
because we've optimized Snapshot to work with Lumen to work and perform a lot better than it used to.
But do keep things in mind. Don't throw the whole kitchen sink at it at first.
Walk yourself through each one of these levels if you load them,
and just be conscious of where your stuff is at, how much items you have,
and exactly how complicated your lighting and your scenes are.
But overall, this is fantastic, and it's a great new update for Unreal.
So I'm going to go ahead and click on our first one here,
and I'm going to say Apply Snapshot.
You'll see in the lower corner here me actually interactively in my screen doing this.
I'll click on the next one here, our little swimwear, and we'll hit Apply Snapshot.
And again, you'll see that update on the fly.
We're only working with three, and everything's working beautifully in our scene.
You see the shadows moving with the palm tree. Fantastic.
And then we'll go to the next one here, evening.
I'm going to hit Apply Snapshot, and then we've got a nice, more evening setting here.
And awesome.
We're able to do this on the fly, and you can now do this on set,
working with your directors, working with your production managers,
working with whoever's in charge of your light,
whether it's big production or small production,
you're able to access this via your iPad,
and you're able to go in here and edit things according to what you need.
Now let's go ahead and go to our tab one, which is our light control.
So we're back at evening now, and now I can control my intensity of my light,
so I can lower the intensity or increase the intensity.
I can go in here and change the color of a light if I need to.
Ooh, that's really gross.
So we'll reset back to default, and we'll say yes to default.
And then we can also control the roll if we need to.
We can control the pitch, move that around.
Let's put that back. There we go.
And we can control the yaw,
all within these settings with this iPad and doing it on the fly.
That's it for this demonstration.
I hope you guys got a lot out of it,
and it makes sense to be able to use things in this particular workflow.
Unreal is a fantastic tool,
and having the option to be able to have these tools at your fingertips
to be able to do this on set is priceless.
Thank you, and have a great day.